our next guest is actor Anthony Ramos he
played both John Laurens and Philip
Hamilton in the Broadway musical
Hamilton I so remember that which won
him a Grammy for cast album so he's also
starred in Spike Lee's Netflix series
it's called She's Gotta Have It A Star
is Born and the musical film I remember
this too in the Heights now Ramos plays
a former U.S army private by the name of
Noah Diaz in the new movie Transformers
rise of the Beast here's a look at what
happens when his character meets the
Transformers for the very first time
I thought after the car chase we were
boys what are you the names were
come on give me a little give me a
little
cute there you go now we're friends
oh great the gang's here they're more
like you
you brought a human here
I'm nobody I ain't even seen nothing I'm
not even seeing anything right now
he is the film is distributed by
Paramount part of the same company as
CBS as you may know Anthony Ramos joins
us first on CBS mornings we welcome you
congratulations to you on your success
Anthony you're killing it on all levels
many different levels but let's focus on
this for just a second because most of
the movie aren't you acting to nothing
nothing they bring in the tennis balls
for rehearsal uh they're like all right
that's optimism that's Mirage do the
whole scene like that and then they're
like yo you got it and you're like yeah
sure sure and then they take the tennis
balls out you just talk to nobody yeah
yeah it's crazy that's
to do to me yeah
yeah it's fun though you know you get to
use your imagination it's a lot of fun
it's a lot of fun it's kind of weird
it's crazy especially when you're like
in the jungle and talking to nobody are
they piping in voices or some actor
standing in with the voice yeah yeah
there's somebody off to the side shout
out to Daniel wherever you are in the
world he was an amazing reader shout out
to Daniel so word on the street is when
you were First cast in the movie you
didn't believe it why
oh because I mean it's transform is the
biggest one of the biggest franchises in
the world you know and like I'm a kid
from the projects and in in Brooklyn you
know uh so it's just a dream for you was
it even dream you had 100 I mean like a
lot of New York kids you do not have a
driver's license I didn't have a
driver's license but you drive a lot in
this movie I don't drive at all okay
still I got my license I had two weeks
to get my license for this film and I
went I got one the last appointment at
the DMV in Red Hook I took the test in
my mom
is that we got your license no no but
I've been to that one for other reasons
no that's the one you want to go to in
Brooklyn those streets are a little
easier than the rest uh that's that's
the plug and then uh and I passed and I
went back and I didn't drive once but
did you even think this dream was
possible for yourself growing up as a
kid trying to decide what you were going
to do I'm fascinated when these kind of
dreams come true yeah I mean I I never
thought you know I didn't even want to
be an actor as a kid I want to be a
professional baseball player and then I
realized that wasn't going to happen and
then uh and you know I got a musical
theater by a kind of accident because I
love music yeah and that was you know I
was like oh okay I could sing and then
they were like you know but you got to
act too
you talk about being a Kid From Brooklyn
uh there's a line that you use in the
film with your little brother home team
yeah and apparently that's something
that's personal to you yeah yeah yeah my
well me and my brother we text that to
each other all the time you know we work
together with that he's like my best
friend you know so we um we always text
each other home team so I'm like yo
thanks for thanks for helping me with
that out he goes your home team you know
my dad said that to us and this little
handshake we do yeah my father he always
be like your home team home team so
um you know yeah and you're able to
incorporate that in the film yeah yeah
yeah with my my little brother in the
movie Dean Vasquez who's one of the most
special young actors I've ever met in my
whole life whoa he's he's amazing I love
you Dean but but I like how you say you
know I knew I could sing and talking
about your singing because you just
released and you just released a song
Viano which means
yeah yeah I'm uh yeah I'm excited we
just just really is Viano I had a a wild
experience two years ago almost two
years ago now and I'm finally writing
about it uh this song's like a year old
probably over a year old but I waited a
while to put it out and finally I'm
ready to you know tell my story and you
know I love your story I first fell in
love with you with Hamilton when you're
rolling it's in the place
that seemed so long ago to you oh those
days yeah 100 really yeah oh it's crazy
It Feels Like Somebody went like this in
the Men in Black you know
people
that happened that happened for real
yeah but you played the two roles in
that film in that musical yeah and what
was that like because you have to swap
out at the second act acting and singing
you hear harder than the tennis ball
acting is is uh uh they're both they're
both special in in their own way but but
um but yeah no it was it was tough man
eight shows a week is no joke and that
show was like three hours so by the end
so everybody thinks he acts and guys
he's a businessman about to open up a
coffee shop
so hopefully we can get that patent in
yeah
check my Instagram for the new name
family and Bill
and Bill continue to soar we are
cheering you on yeah Brothers thank you
so much for getting up early because we
know that's a pain nah it's all good oh
it's all good I'm happy to be here we're
glad you're here Transformers rise of
the Beast opens in theaters this Friday